cette borne et véhicules à deux pas de
la mairie tout près de la gare
versailles rive gauche depuis la fin du
mois d'avril la commune possède 21
véhicules répartis sur trois stations ça
fonctionne très bien parce que le
démarrage en quinze jours trois semaines
on a déjà plus de 160 abonnés annuels
c'est un très très bon complément de
mobilité avec les bus avec la bicyclette
avec la marche à pied pour les
versaillais qui était très demandeur de
ce mode de déplacement entre paris et
versailles et d'autres villes de la
région parisienne dans le courant de
l'année viendront s'ajouter celles de
versailles chantiers et satori quatre
autres stations sont à l'étude
elle devrait voir le jour courant 2010
est à bois d'arcy l'installation est
encore au stade de projet de station
devrait voir le jour à la zone
d'activités de la croix bonnet et près
de l'avenue paul vaillant couturier
grandes artères de la commune
c'est un vrai complément de transport
pour les artisiens mais aussi du point
de vue développement durable puisque les
stations seront équipées de bornes de
rechargement et donc du coup les
artisans pour des véhicules électriques
pourront prendre un abonnement talus et
recharger leurs véhicules sur ces bornes
versailles grand parc finance les
installations à hauteur de 50% avec le
chesnay et vélizy qui propose déjà ce
service
cette agglomération possède pour le
moment très station